the first person that that was actually
cast as Quasimodo was meatloaf really
yep he was not he wasn't cast he read
for it right well got it you know that's
actually really good he was he was like
he was like an almost cast it was like a
callback kind of thing I don't think we
actually put pen to paper yeah I think
that's true I think I think there was
never a signed contract but we got so
far as to meet with meatloaf at a
recording studio Santa Monica Boulevard
and I think Alan was there and we talked
we talked with meatloaf he actually ran
through out there Quasimodo's song he
was really good yeah he was terrific
it was really good I mean it was it was
far along in the process you know like
like almost cast to the point where Kirk
and I were asking each other you know
like on the way back to the car it's
like okay so do we call him meet or mr.
loaf or what we call it you talk to
Mandy Patinkin to about Hunchback right
Oh in one of our casting sessions in New
York Mandy Patinkin came in and actually
read for the part and again Mandy
Patinkin amazing actor incredible career
big fan
disastrous audition really and all that
Gary King brothers oh he brought his own
accompanist I mean we had we had a guy
there who was you know he would he was
on the piano and everybody that came in
and saying he supplied music so his his
accompanist had rearranged the song and
this is what you see on Allen and
sitting in the room in the room he says
oh yes well we took the liberty of
rearranging your song so so yeah and so
so that they played it and Kirk and I
were like oh and
good sweet you can see just like like
turning red you know like the room
behind it was getting dark just like
okay this and and when he finished with
the song and I can't remember who it was
but like like almost immediately they
said Kirk and Gary you guys want to step
outside and we're like okay we went out
sorry cookie went outside and there was
an argument that went on inside we you
know there was just I'll back up just a
little bit because this part is kind of
funny we could hear like sort of a sort
of a animated so to speak discussion
happening on the other side of the door
we were in the yellow and then Mandy
Patinkin came back out ostensibly to
work with us a little the dialogue he
was gonna read a dialogue scene cuz he
hadn't yet for the mood for beef right
right right we were supposed to get him
some feedback and talk a little about
the character so Mandy's very you know
he's very gracious with us and he's
talking to us and kind of nodding and
and and you know he's sort of a little
bit of bit intense then like like in
mid-sentence like Gary and I were
talking and at one point Mandy just goes
guys I'm really sorry I can't do this
and he turns on his heel and he goes
back into the room and shuts the door
and then the fireworks really started I
mean you know the walls shook the
engineer and the casting director came
out you know into the hall with us
they're like oh my god oh my god Mandy
chewed out Stephen so bad that that
Stephen was so pissed he got up and left
so Stephen gets in the elevator and he's
gone Alan puts on his coat in his car
he's in the elevator and he's out of
here so now we've lost Steven right
we're sitting there in this kind of
smoking crater
of a rehearsal studio just happen and
which we have since called the Patang
kittens incident so many drawings were
made about the subject after yeah